[Music]
all right so we're playing a 1400
and let's go e4
we've been playing the danish gambit
almost exclusively
and if it ain't broke uh
wait why am i blanking on the expression
if ain't broke don't fix it
right if it ain't broke don't fix it so
let's see what happens c3
d takes c3 thank you mal srl with a
prime and i'll talk more about this
tonight guys i'll formulate my thoughts
i'll make a couple more
i'll i'll uh address things in more
detail
tonight but let's leave everything at
the door right now
okay so bishop b2 c6
um and that's i think we actually faced
this move
i think we actually faced this move once
and i think the motivation behind it is
to prepare the move d5
but um this square on d5 is well
defended by
three of our pieces so we respond to
this move
in a very um in a very unremarkable way
we need to complete our development we
don't have enough stuff out
to mount any kind of serious threats
against the king so knight f3 is the
move
bishop b4 check and that's a good move
which begs the question what do we do
do we cover with knight c3 do we cover
with knight bd2 or do we move the king
and the danish you can sometimes
actually move the king
that's not the dumbest idea in the world
um now which move can we rule out the
move that we can rule out is knight to
c3 which
may appear to be the most natural
developing move but
uh it covers up the bishop and we want
this damn bishop
to attack g7 that's one of the things
that is so appealing about the danish is
all of these threats that we have
so that leaves us with king f1
realistically and knight b knight b to
d2
um and i'm pretty i'm
pretty indifferent i think both moves
make sense but
let's play more i want to castle i don't
want to move the king around in the
center let's just go knight b to d2
that's probably wrong actually i have a
feeling i think i remember king f1 being
the move here theoretically but
it's fine and again to the point that i
made yesterday i'm not always playing
theory moves i don't know the the i'm no
clue what the theory is here
so i am trying to play the most natural
moves uh because
it can only go so badly if you do that
well he can play d5 but g7 is hanging so
bishop takes hg7
would win the rook so i'm not sure d5 is
justified
f6
okay okay calm down daniel
need i explain anything more yeah this
is this is not the greatest move of
course he's
blunting the bishop but look at the
weaknesses that he's creating on his
king side
and the first thing that i see here is
this knight on g8 which is targeted by
the bishop
it's a type 2 undefended piece so
there's a very natural move here it
doesn't win a piece but
it creates further difficulties for
black in terms of getting his pieces out
and that's the move queen b3 i've talked
about this idea before in the danish
stacking the bishop and the queen i
would have preferred for this battery to
be flipped
then we would have been threatening
checkmate but this is pretty much good
enough
i think he has to yeah he has to take um
and okay so this is interesting i think
a lot of people would grab
instinctively with the knight and we
will take with the knight
we will take with the knight but i just
wanted to point out that king takes
would not be stupid
because the king in the center isn't
great but he's got no pieces out
and there's something to be said for
opening up the e file quickly getting a
rook there and then slamming down e5
but um there is something that gives me
the creeps about that move one second
let me disconnect my headphones from my
phone
i don't know i'm gonna take with the
knight because
see the thing is we're not really in a
hurry to put a rook on anyone he's not
castling any time soon if he moves his
night out right
look at two of our pieces stopping his
king from castling
so i just don't see a way for him to
castle quickly and so i think this is
justified
in the sense that we will tuck our king
away in the king's side
and you know this leads me to the point
that
sometimes playing the most simple chess
is the most reliable kind of chess
okay so knight h6 let's castle
he can go d5 we'll take on d5 he can't
technically castle there but we'll just
take everything on c6 he'll play a
danish gambit of his own
the difference being that he'll lose a
bunch of his pieces queen e7
okay so what should we do now
what should we do now he's not
threatening to castle we should ask
ourselves what his idea is i think his
idea is to bring the knight back to f7
and then he'll be ready to castle so we
don't have forever
a lot of you are saying rockefeller and
i like that move but there's a very
important question to ask yourself in
these kinds of positions and that is
do we need to play rook f1 when you're
preparing a move
you should allocate at least a couple of
seconds to figuring out
whether you even need the preparatory
move in the first place can you
eliminate the middleman
and those of you with sharp tactical
vision will see that you actually do not
you can play e5 straight away
f takes e5 you can take with a bishop
and if he takes that bishop his queen
will get skewered with rook f to e1
um and that's a simple thing that
everybody could do you just ask yourself
do i need
the middleman do i do i need the
preparatory move sometimes the answer is
yes i do sometimes it's no i don't
f5 but that leaves us with a beautiful
pawn on e5
and we should note that that pawn cannot
be captured even if there was no bishop
on v2 and that leaves us
oh it's a pin sorry it's not a your
skewer is the other way around again in
russian it's the same word
i actually have noticed this i get this
confused all the time
and sometimes my students look at me
like what are you weren't you supposed
to be a gm
but to my knowledge it's the same word
in russian so
i i don't really sense the difference
always yeah bishop a3 is a great move
now you can think of this bishop on b2
as having done its job
it's a superfluous bishop we don't need
it anymore its role was to help prepare
e5 now that e5 has already played and
this pawn doesn't need protection
this bishop can see greener pastures
particularly because
the bishop on a3 covers the f8 square
and makes it even harder for him to
castle
get misinformation all the time oh it
would be amazing to put the knight on d6
i don't really see a way to get there
c5 is a great move this guy is good
wait i do see a way to get there let's
get this night
onto this unbelievably juicy
outpost this is even better than a kebab
how do we do that now we need to fly
from
charlotte to paris so we need to go
through london
you know munich is closed the airport is
closed
um now the problem is there's a plane at
our gate
there's a plane at our gate let's get
that plane out of there
yeah bishop d5 bishop d5 now
why d5 because we want the bishop to
remain on this diagonal now we can go to
c4
yeah the knight is the knight is not
wearing a mask he got thrown off the
plane
so bishop d5 because there's no other
good squares i want the bishop to remain
on this diagonal
to make sure that he's not castled okay
and also this centralizes the bishop
it's just visually good
well he can't take on e5 nothing changed
we'll just take back and then we'll
skewer his
god damn it pin his queen
what's wrong with me just misinformation
all over the place calling pins skewers
this is a great example of
how propaganda has seeped into the chess
world
with grandmasters now basically
controlled by large media corporations
okay
yeah this is unavailable for black and
look at this
look at these holes in his position
yeah i do but his knight coming out he
should go knight d4 here and attack my
queen
and then we shouldn't rush with a check
uh we should just move our queen let me
just
note this down
assuming he doesn't play 94 i think he
will but
all right
it's like comes from the word for
connection
i don't know maybe the word skewer does
exist in russian but i don't think so
maybe somebody can tell me i i i've
always thought of it as just
vasco okay well
let's um let's eat wait or let's not
96 maybe he can then take on e5 i think
that's what he's trying to do
he's trying to unpin himself
preemptively so that he can take on e5
but let's not stop calculating if we go
knight d6
we go knight d6 right and he plays queen
takes e5
how can we support the knight in that
position
because we don't have to support the
knight with a pawn we have a piece
that is ready to jump into the action we
don't need to play four we can play
knight d6
but the reason why we can play knight d6
is after queen takes e5 we can play
bishop takes c5
our bishop jumps into the game and the
bishop operates in the capacity of the
pawn
supporting the night now why is this
even a good thing why do you know why
don't we want a pawn to support tonight
isn't that better
well yes in principle but remember queen
takes e5 works in our benefit because it
opens up the position further
and the side that has more active pieces
generally benefits from that so
we kind of want him to take the pawn
anyway for the sake of
opening up the position now he's got v6
he's very solid
and i see the possibility of taking
the knight on c6 which uh
doesn't seem to lead anywhere after d
takes easy but imagine if we had a rook
on d1
x-raying his king then we would be able
to step aside with a knight and win his
queen
so which rook should we put on d1 well
let's think about the other rook
if we put this rook on d1 that restricts
the other rook to come to e1
plausibly he's going to go king c7 after
rook after you want to escape the pin
and if he does we might want this other
rook to come to c1
in order to once again re-pin or
re-skewer the king
so let's go rook after d1 and if he
takes on e5 we will take his knight
and then we will have a devastating
discovery i have to speed up a little
bit here
i don't want to lose on time
yeah that's a good question
but this is not the considerations here
are quite simple
when you're deciding which rook to put
on a square you need to look at the
other rook
what will the other rook be doing where
do you want the other rook to be
and that sometimes requires a prediction
like i made the prediction that he's
going to go king c7 and
then we would put the other rook on c1
yeah he does
they don't call me the prophet for
nothing um okay so
let me think for a second
yeah let's go rook ac1
and um we are we have once again pinned
uh or x-ray x-rays the appropriate term
here x-ray the king
now this is where things get very
tactical okay this is this gets tricky
um we're going to step aside of the
night and i'm making this move quickly
because i don't want to lose on time
this puts him in a very difficult
situation
if he goes king to back to d8 that's why
we put the rook on you and we take his
knight that's a free knight and that's
winning
if he goes king b8 then the queen and
this is kind of elegant
all three of our major pieces have taken
a turn on x-raying the king
if this pawn was gone from b6 we would
have some form of devastating discovery
so what move comes to mind here
this guy is definitely very very
not an easy opponent i like bishop takes
yeah bishop takes c5
blasting open the pathways to his king
and threatening bishop d6 strike he has
to take him then it's still not easy for
us to win
in fact we might want to hold off on the
discovered check until we get all of our
pieces into the attack
yeah so this is uh not an easy game not
an easy opponent
but we're keeping our foot on the gas
pedal and at some point
if you stay calm something will come up
here
yeah so we're going to take with a rook
here we're just going to take no rush
we're going to create another x-ray
against this queen and hopefully this is
going to be the final straw that's going
to lead him to collapsing but should be
seven that's a good move
um okay let me think for a second
there's a line that i'm calculating
which potentially leads to a beautiful
win
but i want to make sure i'm not screwing
it up because if i do
that's not gonna be good okay there is a
really beautiful line here i think
um let me make the moves again i'm sorry
i hate to wait actually
oh my god there's a defense there
yeah no it doesn't work um
sorry i just need to focus here
trying to find a win in that position
there's an insane defense
yeah i think knight d6 is the move here
hmm or an id4 they should all be winning
okay knight before it is i'll show you
guys everything i was thinking but
we're just gonna play it safe i really
wish that would have worked
i think this is completely winning
because just threatening a million
things here
overwhelming him
the the immediate threat is by the way
bishop takes c6 opening up the attack on
his queen and simultaneously threatening
this checkmate
so don't worry i'll i'll walk you no
that's a really good move that rookie
ate
let's go h3 to stop the backrank threats
yeah he's definitely defending super
well but i
i don't see a defense for him here
i just feel like it's it's too many
there's got to be
there's just too many threats
yeah now h3 was important because he was
threatening checkmate rook takes you one
dixie one checkmate
so again queen is x-raying the king
the rook is x-raying the queen which
means we can combine the two yeah it
goes there
that doesn't work we can just take
anyway yeah
and this is the crusher because if he
takes then we take there
and that's a complete disaster for black
so he's gonna lose his queen here
he has to take back and then he loses
his queen i don't
see a defense here okay he takes this
way
we take his queen and now on top of that
we have a
very strong move in this position that
ends the game what move am i thinking of
what move am i thinking of here we have
actually a couple of wins here
96 is what i'm thinking of but but i
look at this position a little bit
longer
i see an even better move it can just
play queen to g3
yeah or 96 it really doesn't matter
let's go 96 he can't bring his king back
because we check man he has
he has to give up his rook and he has
two pieces for the queen and his king is
in
huge trouble there so it's completely
winning queen takes c6
or timmy have lost the match against
version
okay this was a very rich game
tactically rich game
and you can learn a lot from these kinds
of games which is why
you want to play
or tammy i've had the one game lead he
oh my god damon that's
crazy how do you i don't understand
check check and checkmate is very easy
oh my god that's insane
rook b1 goodbye queen a3 lettermate
no there's no such thing as dirty play
in these matches you guys i i won't
if you actually think that there's no
such thing as really a dirty play if you
run the timer out that's fair game
completely
because you want to win the match you
got to do anything to win
that's the nature of bullet and for
artemyev
it's just a big blunder that you know
i'm a big artemia fan but that's just
he you know you've got to have that
awareness although it's easy for me to
say
because you've got to have the timer
open but that can be hard to look at
thank you lactose-fatigue okay
yeah not not playing today um
so small change of plans okay guys so
the accuracy i know you guys are curious
the accuracy was probably not good for
me i
i messed up i probably did not play
precisely at several points
okay it was not bad it was 98.4 to 72.3
um that's better than i expected
all right yeah i was cheating that's
right
all right so danish gambit c6
now
yeah sorry i didn't i didn't i honestly
didn't know i'm not trying to
do the humble brag thing or i'm like i
knew it was high
okay so knight f3 bishop b4 check
and we decided on knight bd2 i think
this is fine
to those of you who thought black can
play d5 the problem with this move
for example e takes d5 c takes d5 who
can spot the most clinical move for
white here
who can spot the most clinical move for
white in this position
well russian parents too trust me
so a lot of you are thinking this and
you're recognizing the pattern
but the secondary pattern is that black
can bring the knight out and defend the
bishop
don't forget about that when you're
considering
this check always check whether no pun
intended whether this can be blocked
now some of you see the oh my god good
thing it doesn't happen tomorrow
let's hope it doesn't have tomorrow some
of you see bishop takes g7
which is fine but this is an example of
tunnel vision you see that the rook is
saying you think i'm winning an exchange
but if you calculate this a little bit
further
black can take the bishop this is
already not that impressive
and exchange is good but it's not
game-winning and if you calculate
further you'll see the pin
you'll notice a move like c3 and this
leads to complete chaos
if the knight moves then black will go
c2 and win the queen
um so instead we look for intermediate
moves we say well can we move this
bishop we can
ah but black is king fa oh man black
does have king f8 here so
still why can't castle and the king is
very weak but
my idea was to first move the bishop
away to safety and then take on g7
um all right
so why is king f1 okay king f1 is okay
because the king is not in any immediate
danger and you can always sort of castle
by hand
and the point here is that the knight on
d2
clutters up the center this queen
doesn't have the same control over the d
file it doesn't quite have the same
mobility
this is a pin it's not a dangerous one
but a pin is a pin that's something you
have to pay attention to
so paradoxically king f1 is less
burdensome on white's pieces
and the way you should think about this
is you know
um knight bd2 is the fuel efficient move
knight bd2 is the sort of the toyota
prius
kind of move king f1 is the let me climb
into my ferrari kind of move
and let's forget about these other
considerations and let's go directly for
uh the immediate initiative and we'll
worry about our king safety later
well bishop c3 is not good because this
bishop is our strongest piece
this is the piece which is doing most of
the attacking as you can see
so this would allow him to bail out our
bishop for his bishop which is not
particularly strong piece
knight b to d2 f6 is a big mistake
nothing wrong with with the toyota prius
um
in fact toyota is a phenomenal car brand
okay
um so knight f6 would i think have been
the lesser evil for him but in this
position
what can white do
what can i do here thank you ted sue's
grid e5 comes to mind but there is a
better move here
let's make the other observations the
bishop is undefended how can we exploit
this
well first thing you might see is queen
b3 that looks like a fork right we're
attacking f7 attacking the bishop
but black can take the knight with check
and that black has the time to castle
you have a two move sequence what do i
always say you need to check what
happens if you switch the move order
start with bishop f7 check then go queen
b3
pick off the bishop and black's king is
going to be in some trouble still i
think this is more double edged thank
you archo
that's awesome f6
is a big mistake because it creates a
permanent weakness
and why is this a permanent weakness
because pawns don't go backward he's
forever going to have to reckon with
this diagonal being very weak
what if knight d5 um if knight d5
then we'll just take the knight and now
we have the possibility of a discovered
attack or discover check against this
against the king here
um okay
so on we go f6 queen b3 now this stage
of the game was very simple knight takes
we castle we go e5 again if he takes we
take back he can't take the bishop
because of the
the pin this is very simple uh so let's
get straight to the tactics bishop a3
now we want this knight to get to d6 how
can we do that we need to go through c4
let's move the bishop out of the way
this is very logical chess knight d6 if
he takes the pawn on e5 we take on c5
and we support the knight
if and he played b6 we go rook d1
x-raying the king
x-raying the king and now we get into
the complicated tactics right
okay so the
knight b5 check forces the king into one
direction
which clarifies how we are going to
proceed
if the king get goes back to d8 that's
why we put a rook on d1
we can take the knight on c6 everybody
should be able to follow this
bishop can't be captured we're up a
piece and we're still attacking right
um we'll race for the prize it's just
because it's such a central outpost and
the knight just clamps down
sits on black's position all right
that z that is not 30 moves ahead that's
that's a two move sequence
and it's particularly facilitated by the
fact that
i explained why we put the rook on d1 in
the first place so you should be primed
to consider that
not okay sorry we played rook c1 first
all right
dude so knight b5 check he's got to go
to the b
file and in my mind i immediately
see as you guys also should see that the
queen is x-raying the king
and that's why the move bishop takes e5
comes to mind
because we have to get this b-pawn out
of the picture so that we can give a
discovered check against the king and
the way to do that
is to incentivize it to move and we
incentivize it by threatening bishop d6
hope that makes sense b takes c5
and this is the hardest moment in the
game this in the next move
i think everybody might have been
surprised why i didn't
move the knight away and that's because
i just didn't see a good discovered
check
okay perhaps some of you spot knight d6
check
but black goes king c7 guys hold off on
the drama
hold off on the um
on the discussion i'll be streaming
tonight and i'll comment more on it
yeah thanks uh thanks lona but right now
i'm doing the speed run and
like i always say we try to keep this
community a certain way
and to keep it a reliable place where
people can come for chess
primarily and i only discuss this
drama stuff if i absolutely have to um
and i try to limit it
okay so let's again exercise our
responsibility to keep it that way
um particularly if i if i ask now i know
that some of you are coming in
um just in the last couple of minutes
and you didn't notice that i'm not
going to ban anybody or time anybody out
but it's sort of a
zero tolerance thing once i tell you and
you're in the stream please
abide by that all right so king c7
and there's no follow-up the king is
safe here
so knight d4 king c7 the king is safe
here
if you look carefully you have no good
squares for the night now that's not a
reason to panic
because um i talked previously about
kinetic versus potential energy
and kinetic versus potential energy and
i drew that
graphic that was many many months ago
but some of you guys have been in my
stream for a while remember
uh do you guys want a refresher on that
or should i just
get on with life i don't know if this is
too much talking
um okay refresher
quick refresher um
most of you have taken physics i'm by no
means an expert
i kind of sucked at physics um
particularly i sucked at labs and
following instructions
nothing has really changed um but the
one concept that stuck with me is
uh kinetic versus potential energy
so we take a look at a roller coaster
and that's the the most classic
illustration of it if we take a look at
how a roller coaster operates
so basically this is uh the
king dakar roller coaster in new jersey
you can see how maca s that thing is
so you can see that at this moment
and they're all screaming now this
roller coaster doesn't actually stop
um most roller coasters go up the hill
and then they stop
completely and that allows us to better
illustrate this this notion but at the
moment that they're at the very top of
the first hill
um if i'm not butchering this the roller
coaster has maximum
uh potential energy because it's at its
slowest speed
but it's about to speed up to its
fastest speed
right and then but it's and then the
moment that it's on the bottom of the
hill
this is pretty terrifying um right now
it's at the bottom of the first hill and
it's got
the most kinetic energy which means
energy generated from movement
but it's got the least potential energy
because it's at the bottom of the hill
it doesn't
you know it doesn't have that drop
that's coming okay so that's the usual
illustration i think now well
let's go back to the speed run
i've sort of plagiarized this for the
purposes of chess
and in chess when we evaluate the
placement of a piece
we tend to think of it in terms of its
kinetic energy what is the piece doing
we see an outpost like the knight on d6
and we think well
you know we look at a knight like this
and we think well this knight is amazing
right it's controlling all these squares
it's doing all of this stuff
but then we look at a piece which is
let's say blocked in by our own pawn
and we assume that that piece is bad but
a piece like that isn't always going to
be bad
and that's where this notion comes in
you have to be able to look at a piece
and evaluate not only its kinetic energy
what it's doing at the moment
but what it could be doing in a
particular change of circumstances
and this could also be applied to a set
of pieces
now what is an example of this let me
give you one
when we look at this position we have
opposite side castling right
we might see a square on d5 right we
might occupy with the knight and this
knight will have a lot of
kinetic energy it's controlling a lot of
squares is doing a lot of stuff great
everybody should be on board with that
but let's look at this piece of garbage
on b2
total piece of garbage right why is this
bishop why does this bishop look bad
what what about this bishop makes me say
that
the wife and the kids are great
yeah it's blocked by the pun so what is
this fool doing there
but it's got very little kinetic energy
it's not doing anything at the moment
but imagine if this pawn were gone this
would be the greatest
the biggest beast in the history of
pieces
i mean particularly if we mounted a
battery against b7
that bishop could win the game so even
though the bishop
is bad right now under a change of
circumstances which may or may not
happen
this bishop might become very very good
it might become the game-winner
watch what happens now we move our
pieces around i try to get my queen
there
you know i'm hoping he goes f5 which
which would be kind of dumb he doesn't
do it
blah blah blah you know i move my king
back we maneuver our pieces
and all of a sudden an opportunity
presents itself
and we move our pieces all of a sudden
and opportunity presents itself here it
still looks like black is better
because black's bishop looks much better
than whites but what did my opponent
miss there is a tactic in this position
i've shown this game before this game is
in my book also i think it's a nice game
rook takes f7 is great he can't take
because of rook takes c8 check
and of course if he takes the rook on c4
with his rook then my rook on f7 is safe
so he plays queen takes c4 and he gets
two pieces for the queen
but now my queen drives into g5
and all of his pawns are dead meat and
guess which pawn in particular is then
first comes e5 he tries to win some of
my pawns
and finally about 20 moves after i
showed you the initial position
what move did i play in this position
move 41
it's finally time for this bishop on g2
that was dead the entire game
to come alive and win the game for white
and this bishop wins me the game it
combines with the queen
and the scenario that i laid out is
exactly what happens and this bishop is
behind
all of it and in fact the bishop
contributes to the checkmate
because by defending b7 so
i'm obscure i'm leaving out a lot of
details here but i think you guys get
the point
um so when you're looking at a piece
think not only about the squares that
it's controlling currently but what it
could be doing
under a change of circumstances now we
come back to the game
now we come back to the game and the
thing to notice
in this position is that this pair of
pieces the queen and the knight
are maybe not the strongest right now
there's no good discover check but under
a slight change of circumstances
um this is going to be tremendously
powerful and that basically motivates
how i play in this position so sometimes
rather than
immediately cashing in you want to bring
more pieces
into the fire and keep the tension in
order to
allow for the potential energy of your
pieces to be realized
or actualized all right anyways
so bishop b7 and now the move knight d4
and see that's exactly what happens
because i'm now x-raying his queen
the threats along the b-file are much
stronger than they were before
so if he goes random move i play bishop
takes c6 i'm attacking his queen
if he takes i take his queen if he takes
c5
this is just checkmate and all of this
happens because i brought this rook into
the game
he went rookie e8 which is a nice move
actually obviously
threatening checkmate so i go h3 i make
some loaf for the king so
he should have probably gone knight g4
that would have been the best move yeah
but i think i can still take on c6 here
and escape via f1 and e2
all right so rookie at h3 king c7 and
now the very simple bishop c6
um there were some really beautiful
lines that i was calculating
and i was calculating them here before
knight d4
i was calculating the move bishop takes
c6 immediately
and after queen takes c5 don't
limit yourself just to this area of the
board look at the entire board what move
can you spot here
think queen thinks c7 that's a mating
square boom and our queen swoops into c7
it's checkmate we're happy wait a minute
not
not that simple black can play d6 and
try to throw a pawn in the way
no problem though right you don't want
to take with a queen that trades queens
but we can take with the
we don't want to do this we can take
with a rook and again we have a
potential discovery check against the
king
and what makes this quite nice is if he
gives queen c one checkmate
wait a second that's not checkmate we
can step back with our rook
discover check against the king that
seems to lead to mate i'll get to that
in a second
if he tries to sidestep the discover
check we have a really cool tactic here
we've already sacrificed one rook
that's what makes this nice thank you
trying to learn what move do we have in
this position
we can spot the c7 square that's still a
mating square
what's stopping us from going there well
it's the rook that's all we need to know
check and checkmate down two rooks
bye then i did one final check
no pun intended and i looked at this
position for just one more second
and i spotted an insane defensive
resource here black is the move f4
this is quite unusual actually covering
the check attacking white's queen
counter-attacking it
the rook on d1 is still hanging and
white is out of moves
wherever this queen goes it has to keep
the rook defended otherwise it's going
to be checkmate so you're limited to a
move like this
but then black screen returns and takes
the bishop and the attack dies and black
is up a rook and a piece
so pretty insane stuff and this line
i concluded doesn't work so that's why i
played the patient knight d4
and this is much simpler we just win the
queen and then we win everything else
so the lesson here yeah so if you play
queen f1 or
queen f3
then he's still ah that's probably a
better idea but he can take with a
bishop now
he can take with the bishop and attack
the queen on f3
insane complications here and these
games just sometimes happen
uh they just happen and that's part of
it okay
so any questions about this line can't
you just take his queen well if i take
his queen
then he takes my queen and you might say
well that's good right we win the pun
but remember you've sacked a rook
we've already sacrificed a rook so we're
just down a rook in the end game
always keep in mind the material count
with which you start because that allows
you to determine whether a line like
this is good or not
um
can can't we then checkmate stacking the
queen on d8 ah
oh like this i i thought about that but
it's not made he can cover the check
with a bishop
sadly sag but true
and so then we play the move knight d4
no problem and this is crushing
this is too many threats here um
what if queen f3 bishop takes c6 without
pj what if queen f3
sorry one second i keep skipping the
moment
queen f3 bishop c6 queen d3 you want to
go here
well where can i put this queen to
prevent that i can put it on c5 i don't
think you have a follow-up and i have
the b7 square for my king
okay guys i think that's enough for this
game and the end was very simple bishop
takes we take the queen we check the
night and we win everything else
[Music]